welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer security
attack vectors and techniques
so we're going to talk about a
particular attack vector that can be
used to compromise your
computer security uh specifically social
engineering and then after our
discussion on social engineering we're
going to look at a variety of
technical issues involved in various
types of attacks on computing systems
social engineering is one of the easiest
ways to
compromise somebody's computer security
it's also
the one area where you as a
non-programmer can make a huge
difference in protecting
your computer security basically in
social engineering the attacker is going
to ignore
the technical aspects of the security
system
and instead go for the weakest link
which is the humans involved in the
process
so for example in the old days
somebody would call up the tech support
for a company and say
hey i'm bill gates ceo uh
i forgot my password can you go ahead
and reset my password
and while that may not have happened at
microsoft this has definitely happened
at other companies
at this point of course that whole
process is much more automated but
nevertheless these sorts of things
continue to happen
so if somebody's trying to break into a
particular account they call tech
support pretending to be you
they may not be able to get through the
first time but they slowly gather more
and more information by talking to
different
tech support staff our customer support
staff about that person
and over time they're able to get enough
information about this person that whose
account they're trying to break into
in order to fake out the tech support
person or
customer support person into thinking
they really are who they say they are
this is particularly problematic for
famous people who already have a lot of
information out about them
um and you may require you may remember
that a while back there was a
a series of hacks where different
actresses had their photographs stolen
and it's believed that this is the
technique that was used
they called tech support pretended to be
that particular actress
they were convincing enough that the
tech support people were willing to help
them out
and reset the password or something like
that
and then they were able to break into
account that way
probably the best known example of a
social engineering attack is phishing
phishing is where you receive an email
or text message purportedly from a
company and
that attack attempts to get you to
enter account information and password
or otherwise send along
secure data that the attacker should not
have access to
so one thing to keep in mind based on
what you now know
from this class is that it is trivially
easy to reproduce a web page
what do i need to do in order to get a
web page to look exactly like the
original web page well i copy over the
html file i copy the css
i may copy the images and some really
brazen
attacks you don't even bother copying
the images you just use the real images
on the real website and you just have
your own html and css
um so you know it's really easy to
perfectly exactly replicate a web page
so it looks exactly like the original
um so what are you going to do to
prevent these types of attacks well
don't ever click on a link on an email
message if you get a message that
there's a problem with your account
don't click on the link instead
go to the main website for that company
i say the main website meaning
also don't just look at the url provided
in the email message and try and type it
word
you know letter for letter um you know
www
dash tech support dash you know don't do
that just go to the main website
type it into the web browser yourself um
or uh alternatively
call the company directly using a
telephone number get the telephone
number from somewhere other than the
email message
like let's say it's claiming to be your
credit card flip the back of your actual
physical credit card look at the number
there
call that number do not call the any
number provided in the email message
it's call the number on the back of your
card and say hey i got this email
message i don't know if it's a
fraud or this is a real deal can you
tell me what's going on so
you know be very very leery of clicking
on
anything in an email message
remember email is very insecure the
sender can be very easily faked
the reply to field can be manipulated so
the the email message that you're
replying to is not going to the original
sender it's going to some somebody else
um smtp servers these are the servers
used to send email messages as opposed
to the ones that are used to receive
and read our email messages were
originally designed
for open access um i think they are
more and more requiring people to
uh use accounts but nevertheless the
original
architecture was anybody could use any
email relay to send their messages so
the whole system was just designed
completely for insecurity
in addition traditionally the email
messages themselves have not been
encrypted um what has been changing
is that many of the
major email sites have switched to
requiring https and so as long as you
are communicating with the server using
https
any traffic to that website is using
https so if you for example were to go
to www.gmail.com
using https
people would not be able to see that
traffic specifically
but just keep in mind the whole email
system again is
is very badly designed from a security
standpoint a lot of it is just
completely insecure
and again it's trivially easy to fake
the sender on an email message
okay so i think one of the scariest
types of attacks is a spear phishing
attack
whereas general phishing emails i mean
we probably all get them
in fact i know you get them because
you're stanford student and
stanford gets attacked so we get
messages purported to be from stanford
security
telling us to log into a particular
thing reset our password
and hopefully they're pretty obvious
although you know i'm sure it could be
pretty easy to accidentally click on the
message and
end up being john podesta who you recall
clicked on a message he thought was from
google and reset his password and
therefore all the hillary clinton
campaign emails got
got released um spearfishing though is
much more difficult to prevent
what happens in spear phishing attack is
the attacker wants to attack a
very specific person the attacker is
going to study their target
they're going to learn about the
target's jobs what sorts of
things that the target carries out on a
regular basis what sort of email
messages the target might expect to
receive
who the target's co-workers are what
sort of
positions they carry what sort of
messages they might be
expected to send the target and then
what they do is they create a carefully
crafted email of the type that the
target would typically receive
that email may appear to be coming from
a co-worker
and in fact they can add an extra
information into the email message
depending on how thoroughly they want to
research this you know like
hey and it was great singing at the
party last friday where we saw
sarah and john and so it looks exactly
like it's coming from your co-worker
and so you go ahead and click on the
link
or you open the attachment or whatever
um and so again i don't know a great way
to prevent this
sort of attack other than just being
super super paranoid
um i will say when i receive
messages from students that have
attachments i'm far more likely to
try and open those attachments on my
ipad than i am
on a pc because the ipad
is more of a walled garden where it's
difficult for attackers to
break out of the email box and do
attacks
on my computer so you know obviously in
a lot of cases i do
have to open attachments on messages
from students and i don't know who the
students are so
you know this is an area where you're
super vulnerable
again i don't know any particularly
great ways to prevent it but
i do think my opening email messages on
the ipad
is better than opening them on
on my my pc the pc is just easier to
attack
and it's more likely that anyone not
listening to this video
would have send send an attack on the
assumption that i would be opening on a
pc
all right it's also possible to mix
social engineering with more technical
attacks so uh you know i mentioned
earlier that
last lecture when we talked about how
stuxnet was designed to attack the
iranian nuclear
refinement facilities probably the
iranian nuclear refinement facilities
had an air gap which is to say that they
were not directly attached to the
internet
um so in order to get
on the internal network not attach the
internet
uh whoever attacked those computers
must have had a way to get into that
non-attached network and so one way of
doing this is with the usb drive so they
could have sent in an actual physical
agent and stuck a usb drive
into one of these computers but it turns
out that using social engineering you
can actually get people to stick
things into their own usb drives without
uh
you having to actually be there and so
the department of homeland security did
a test where they went outside of
government facilities and they dropped a
bunch of usb
drives and what was actually on the usb
drive was
uh a program that would
contact the department of homeland
security and say hey
uh such-and-such usb drive was plugged
in
um here's the computer was plugged into
uh
you know and then homeland security
would follow up and say hey
we dropped this dummy attacker usb
drive out of the parking lot somebody
plugged it into such and such a computer
but that drive could also be not from
the department of homeland security
not a part of a test exercise but
actually contained some sort of a
malicious payload
what they found was that 60 of the
drives they dumped into parking lots
were picked up and plugged into
computers
but if they actually added a logo to the
usb drive
uh 90 of them were plugged in so like
let's say you're out in front of the
u.s geological survey office you put a
usgs
logo on the drive you drop it in the
parking lot that greatly increases the
chance somebody's going to take it and
plug it into one of the computers
um to bring in another example at the
recent
u.s north korean conference um some
company handed out a bunch of
usb powered fans and people like
it's really hot this outside this is
really nice
i have this fan i want to be able to use
this mini fan
oh look it's got a usb connector
that's providing power all i need to do
is plug this into my
computer usb port to provide power and
then i will have a nice fan
and the security experts were like uh
this is a really bad idea
they did study them as far as they were
able to discern none of them had
payloads but
um you know you could easily imagine
somebody being like oh this is a cute
gimmick oh i understand i need to plug
into my computer provide
power that's pretty normal great let's
go ahead and do this
and in fact it includes some sort of a
payload that attacks your computer
so don't plug anything into any of your
computer ports
um unless it's coming from a trustworthy
source
okay so um again i i really do want to
emphasize social engineering because
this is the one
attack area that you all can make the
biggest difference
and so you know pay attention again
with the phishing attacks never never
never click on a link
in an email message assume that it's
leaving you somewhere nefarious
even if it looks legit so there's
various techniques that people can do
to make addresses look legitimate even
though they're not
so you know maybe the normal dot is
replaced by
dash so you know just be super super
careful
don't click on those links instead again
just
open up a web browser and you know the
name of the company
you know what their regular web address
is go to that regular web address and
log in that way or again call them up by
phone okay now we're going to take a
look at more technical ways
attacks can occur the first one i wanted
to talk about is something called sql
injection
and so uh i really like this cartoon
from xkcd
thank you to xkcd for allowing use of
their cartoons by nonprofits
uh there's a link to the cartoon down
below um
i think this really illustrates sql
injection really well so here's uh
here's a little cartoon
uh you can see somebody's calling um
this mother
and they say hi this is your son's
school we're having some computer
trouble
and she says oh dear did he break
something and they say in a way
did you really name your student did you
really name your son
robert quote parentheses
semicolon drop table students semicolon
oh yes little bobby tables we call them
well we've lost this year's student
records i hope you're happy
and i hope you learn to sanitize your
database inputs
so what's going on here this is an
injection attack in an injection attack
the attacker enters
code in a place where the system only
expects text
so the idea here is here's the name of
the student
um robert quotepren
and so that quote after the name robert
terminates the string
from the standpoint of whoever is taking
this string from this
text field and sticking it into
part of a sql command and so they're
basically just taking
uh text inserting it into
a pre sql command is slapping
this text string onto the end of
some text that they've already provided
and
so the effect here is that end
quote after robert terminates the string
and then the rest of this stuff gets
directly inserted in as an
actual command which will actually be
executed by the computer
in this case using the sql database and
the result is
it destroys the students table
so the solution to this is you need to
do what's called
sanitize your inputs and so the idea
here is
you need to set up your code in such a
way that anything the user provides
is strictly treated as text and cannot
be accidentally interpreted as a command
so really a
sql injection attack or any injection
attack
um is the result of the programmer being
sloppy
and writing code that's quick and easy
for them to write
without going through the extra step of
saying i'm going to take this input
that the user's entered and i'm not just
going to attach it to the end of
some pre-existing command i'm actually
going to convert the entire thing
explicitly to something that cannot be
treated as a command
and that's what i'm going to use as a
string
we've talked earlier in the quarter
about how
when you have the name of an html file i
recommend you just use
letters numbers and the dash
and that if you use additional
characters like say the space character
they actually get encoded in the special
url encoding so
a space for example you've probably seen
this occasionally on actual websites
a space actually gets converted to a
percent 20
which ends up being the ascii code for
for space and so that's an example of
encoding so
what's going on there is the coding
process is saying
i don't want to treat this as a space
which has actual syntactic meaning in
places where
i might use the string so i'm going to
convert it to the sequence of characters
percent to
zero which cannot be misinterpreted as
part of the
syntax character for whatever purpose i
might be using this particular string
for
so you need to do the same thing or the
programmer needs to do the same thing
on their side they need to take that
whatever the user's entered
and use some sort of encoding that is
going to remove any of the characters
that might be misinterpreted
in the particular language in our little
example here in the sql language
as potential commands
okay cross-site scripting um contrary to
this
the name of this particular text
technique this is another type of
injection attack
in this case though we're actually going
to inject
script into somebody else's web page
and so an example of this is suppose
we've got a
website that displays user names or
maybe user comments like maybe it's a
bulletin board
or it's a newspaper that's running its
own comment
section and what they do is they allow
people to enter say for example their
name they allow them to enter a comment
uh they take that information stuff into
the database and then
when somebody else comes to visit that
website they take that name
and comment and just stick it back out
on the web page
so what you're going to do in this
particular type of attack is instead of
entering a username or maybe instead of
entering that comment
you're actually going to stick in
javascript code including a script tag
and if the server is not sanitizing its
inputs it's just taking the information
that the user has entered into the text
field or the text area
it's going to stick that script tag back
out and it will send
your javascript that you've injected
onto anybody's
web page that visits uh that website
so that's a credits chris site scripting
attack
and the protection against cross-site
scripting is to
you know sanitize your inputs make sure
that
regardless of what the user enters it is
not treated as
actual html that
it is instead treated just as text
so you know maybe you can get rid of
that less than sign
or you can look specifically for tags as
you say tags are not allowed
get rid of any less than signs greater
than signs or something like that
okay click jacking click jacking attacks
causes the user to unintentionally click
on something
this can be used for a bunch of
different purposes
so for example could be used to increase
ad counts
or it could be used to cause the user to
inadvertently purchase something through
amazon's one-click purchase link
okay let's walk you through how click
jack attack works
this requires knowledge of a bunch of
different
html tags and css properties
so the first one is an iframe an iframe
tag allows the user or the creator of a
web page to place
a different html page within the main
html page
so in this particular case i'm using the
iframe tag and
you know i'm sure we've got cat fans out
there who are
unhappy with all my dog examples so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to put a cat example in the middle
of my dog example here
and so you can see that cat
section down in the bottom right hand
corner that is actually a different html
file and it's been inserted by using
this iframe so as you can see the iframe
refers to
source cats.html and so we're actually
going to load up the cats.html file
so the cat file has its own section
which is being displayed in the
web browser within my dogs
file here
step two um i need to know about
something called cascading style teach
positioning cascading style sheets
positioning allows me to
move elements around the web page and
place them wherever i want so in this
particular case i have moved the
cat's iframe from the lower right and
i'm actually placing it in the top left
hand corner
and when you place something absolutely
it actually overlays anything that's
underneath it so
the cat's iframe is now on top of the
information about dogs
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to change the opacity
of that iframe i've reduced the opacity
to 25
so we can actually see it but in a real
click jacking attack which you could
make it just completely invisible so
what we've got is we've got
a part of our web page
which actually is a different website or
a different web page in this particular
case it's a different web page
cats.html and dogs.html are on this on
the same
website but this could just as easily be
a different website say for example
amazon and it would be completely
invisible so that's there
on the web page but the user can't
actually see it
and then the last thing we do is we have
something on our web page that
we think the user will click on uh so
you know maybe there's a link there or
there's a button which claims it does
something
and so the user clicks on a particular
location on our web page
but what they're actually clicking on is
they're clicking on the invisible iframe
which is actually a different website
say for example an invisible copy of
amazon
positions exactly so that the one-click
purchase
button is in the exact location where
we're making the user think if they
click on that location something
different will happen so they
they go to our website they click on you
know what they think is
one thing but they're actually clicking
on an invisible iframe
showing something we're trying to get
them to purchase
with the one click button directly on
the location where they're clicking
okay so how do we prevent a click
jacking attack
so this is really up to the websites who
don't want the cervitech to happen to
them or their customers and so what you
can do
if you're amazon is you can make sure
that your web page will not be displayed
within an iframe
there's several different techniques to
do this um you can include
information the http header uh you'll
recall that that includes
things like um hey this is how long
this web page is good for this is when
it expires or this is a particular
encoding we've got
you can also send information in those
headings that say
web browser don't place me inside of an
iframe
um you can also use javascript to force
your web page to the top of the frame
hierarchy so
there's a bunch of different ways to
prevent click jacking but it does depend
upon
the creator of a website realizing that
click jacking is a thing
and making sure that
their website can't be used in
conjunction with a click jacking attack
one thing that some programs depend upon
particularly in particular web browsers
depend upon is something called sandbox
security
and so the idea behind sandbox security
is
client-side programmers running in a web
browser can do a certain number of
things
to interact with the computer so for
example they can control what's being
displayed
in the web browser window and so things
that the
website can do those are considered
within the sandbox
um and things that that website can't do
are considered outside of the sandbox
so for example accessing files on the
user's computer that it's outside the
sandbox so a web browser
will not allow a website to directly
access the file system
accessing the camera and microphone are
generally outside of the sandbox
although
i think increasingly you may see that
that that's sort of included
in the sandbox but needs special
permissions but the basic idea here is
uh the program in this case the web
browser
is saying hey in order to
allow people to create cool and
interesting websites we want them to
have access to a whole bunch of
different capabilities
that stuff is going to be in the sandbox
but then we need a clear delineating
line on what is outside the sandbox and
what they can't access so
you know in the case you're wondering uh
probably to freak this out but this
comes from the idea of
you can put your kid in the sandbox and
the kid can play around with their toys
uh and as long as they stay in that
sandbox they're in a safe environment
but we don't want them to uh you know
get out of the sandbox and
you know maybe the pool's nearby we
don't want to go to the pool we don't
want them to
actually get in with the dogs at the dog
park
so that's the idea behind sandbox
security
now the one thing to be aware of is
there are a variety of different ways to
get outside of sandbox
and in particular plugins or extensions
often have access outside of the sandbox
so you should be really cautious
installing plugins or extensions
i think the web browsers have gotten a
bit better on specifically telling you
what that web browser plug-in wants
access to
but just be aware if you
stick in a plug-in that plug-in may have
access to absolutely everything
so if you go to website and the website
is like hey
you need to download this plug-in in
order to use this
view this web page properly you know
unless you're
sure you trust that website and you
trust whoever made that plugin
say no it's not worth it to randomly see
something in three dimensions
and risk compromising your whole web
browser security including all your
banking information so you know
say no unless there's a good reason to
say yes and unless you really trust this
person
okay uh on a somewhat related note
there's something called drive by
download
and drive by download tries to get you
to install malicious software so our
example of the web browser plugin
that could be an example of drive by
download
how do we get the user to install
software well one thing we might do is
we might depend upon the gullibility
of the user so they visit our website
and you know we claim there's a plugin
that they need to download
or uh you know we start up a download
message to be like hey we think you have
a virus click here and we'll clean it up
for you
alternatively web browsers will
sometimes
have security vulnerabilities that allow
the website to download something on the
computer directly
so a computer or a web browser
vulnerability
could be identified where if you visit
the website it forces the download or
the installation of something
okay man in the middle attacks uh in the
man-in-the-middle attack what we do is
we insert a malicious computer between
the victim's computer and the computer
they are trying to communicate with
and the idea behind a man-in-the-middle
attack is we want to make it invisible
to the victim that they actually are
being attacked
so suppose i'm trying to communicate
with my bank and there's a malicious
computer between me and my bank
and when i enter my name and password i
think i'm communicating with my
bank but what's actually happening is
i'm passing my name and password
to the malicious computer and the
malicious computer is taking that
information and passing it onward to my
bank
the bank sends the information back to
the malicious computer thinking it's me
and the malicious computer passes the
information on to me
and as far as i'm concerned it looks
like i'm actually properly communicating
with my bank
but in fact there's a hacker in between
us
this can among other things get be used
to get around
uh two-factor authentication where um
i try and log into my bank but my
account is set up with two-factor
authentication which is a really good
thing we'll talk more about it next
lecture
where the bank sends me maybe a text
message with a number and it says okay
patrick um i see you're trying to log in
uh
you seem to be logging in from this
random location i don't know about so
i texted you a message with an
identification number
and so what can happen is i enter my
name and password
into the man in the middle the compute
malicious computer in the middle
it passes on my login
information to the my bank computer
the bank computer sees this come from a
new location
says okay i text you a message
and says enter in
the id number or unique code that i just
sent you
the man in the middle passes that
request on to me
i look on my phone i see the number
i enter it i pass it on to the hacker in
the middle
and the hacker passes it on the bank the
hacker is now into
my bank account
okay um if security is working properly
and you are using security
man-on-the-middle attacks should not
work so there are a couple things that
the person running the man on the middle
attack needs to have
in order to get these things to work
first thing is the man in the middle
requires
the computer to be in the middle so
you know it's it's not like it's
necessarily that easy getting between me
and my bank
but there are ways it can be done uh
particularly like if it's
the nsa or the fbi and they really want
to attack me well
you know they can get uh some sort of a
court order and actually stick something
on the line between say me and the rest
of the internet so yeah
that that's doable uh but in general
something needs to happen that is going
to allow the attacker to insert their
computer between
uh me and the computer that they want to
simulate they also need a way to
overcome
the identity protections and encryptions
used by the the website and by my web
browser
assuming i'm actually using them if i'm
not if i'm
communicating with something using http
which is the non-secure version of
the web protocol instead of https which
is a secure version
then all bets are off then it's just
super easy then they just have to get
between me and the website
okay how can how can they get around
these problems well
um you know you may have heard people
say
don't connect to random uh
wi-fi points or be cautious at web cafes
and and other situations where you know
you sit down at starbucks
oh here's a wi-fi router that looks like
it's starbucks sure let me just go ahead
and connect
in there because this is one place where
you can insert a man in a metal attack
so you know i think i'm communicating
with starbucks wi-fi but in fact i
am communicating with hackers wi-fi the
hacker is now between me
and the rest of the internet and they
can run their man in the middle scheme
how do you get around this certification
encryption issue one thing
is you can assume the user will just
accept the certificates
so if you log into the stanford unix
machines um they will send you this big
long
identification string saying hey here's
my security identification
you can double check and make sure that
this really is the stanford computer it
says
it is and the thing about the stanford
unix computers is there are dozens of
them so there are dozens and dozens of
these
uh identification strings
and unless and so basically every time
you log into one of these computers you
might actually
be logging into a different one so you
know the first time i might be logging
into rice.stanford.iu it might actually
be rice12
next time it might be rice5 next time it
might be rights 3 then it might be rice
and so these all have different very
long unique identification
strings and so if i start getting lazy
i don't bother looking up those
identification strengths and saying oh
yeah that really is rice 12.
i just accept it this would allow
somebody who's a man in the middle to
pretend to be one of these computers and
me not realize
that it's actually a hacker's computer
another possibility is to get a real
fake certificate
and so just as an example
the dutch certification authority
denoter was hacked
and its private keys were compromised
and so whoever hacked them and got a
hold of their private keys
was able to generate new certificates
claiming to be from diginotar which was
considered a reasonable certification
authority at the time
the web browsers have since been fixed
to not allow
diginotar certificates to be used and
the company's gone belly up
um we also talked about i think i talked
about earlier that
when we talked about certification
authorities that somebody got one of the
certification authorities to issue them
a certificate claiming microsoft when in
fact they weren't microsoft
it's also possible to get the user to
install a new certification authority so
you visit the website and
you get a message saying hey
this website is using a certificate i
don't recognize the certification
authority
do you want to add hackers r us as the
uh as a trusted certification authority
and
hope that the user is dumb enough to say
yes this is why again
be extremely cautious adding new
certification authorities to your
web browser in general there isn't a
great reason
at this point for somebody to use a
non-standard certification authority
uh certificates have gone cheap enough
um
from reasonable certification
authorities that this should not be an
issue anymore
but uh you know the user visits the
website
uh they think it's their bank it's not
their bank because they've been
redirected by the man in the middle
they get a message saying hey your bank
says
uh it's got the certificate but you need
to prove this particular certification
authority
uh not you could easily see an iv user
being like okay i don't know what the
heck that is i guess this is fine i'm
gonna go ahead and click on the yes
and so they think they're now
communicating with their bank
we've also had this was really scary but
we also had
a weakness in one of the wi-fi protocols
of wpa2
that actually allowed a particular type
of attack to
grab the encryption key
this was discovered we hope first by a
white hat hacker
and so uh these are the good guys
and so they basically said hey if i do
this and that
i can actually get around the security
on wpa2
and so they notified everybody wpa2 is
not secure
um we don't know of anybody who
discovered this before
uh everybody was notified but it's
certainly possible somebody else
discovered this
ahead of time and was using this in
order to perform man in the middle of
tags
okay another issue that will come up
particularly if you're developing a
website or you're
writing software is
if you are using somebody else's
software on your website or you're using
open source
code as part of a project you're working
on
you inherit the vulnerabilities of that
software
so just as an example um
i know a bunch of people who are working
on this game project
and i visited their website and i
repeatedly was taken
to a third website
which was clearly not associated with
the original website you guys have
probably all seen this before where
you go visit a website and um
you know you instantly get taken to
random
download this game or you know some
other thing that clearly has nothing to
do with the original website
what's going on there well so i notified
them
and they told me that they
they didn't realize this was happening
because they never visited their website
using a ios web browser
they always visited just on their pcs
but they did some research and it turned
out that they were using a plug-in on
their website a
wordpress plugin and that that wordpress
plugin had been compromised
there was a new version of that plug-in
that avoided the problem but
um but yeah basically because they used
this
wordpress plugin that had been written
by somebody else and that wordpress
plugin had been
hacked uh their website was basically
now hacked
um
so while the people who wrote that
plug-in
had not intended to uh
you know cause problems they hadn't
intended it to be a just a regular nice
plug-in that people could put in their
wordpress
websites in some cases the owner of that
plug-in
or other open source project that you're
depending upon
may actually end up maliciously changing
their code so there's a couple
circumstances where this
could occur one is if you're using open
source code open source code means that
anybody can go ahead and go in and
modify the code
so the best prevention for this is to
make sure that
you are working with open source code
that is widely used the more widely it
is used
the more likely there are lots of people
looking at this code
and making sure that if anybody inserts
something into the code it's going to be
noticed
and will be shut down if you're using
some open source
project that's only being used by you
know like a dozen people
are those dozen people security experts
are they paying attention what's going
on with that code
um and so it's relatively easy to
insert malicious code into those sorts
of projects so be
super careful using open source code
that is not
widely used and widely studied
in addition um there have been
incidences where somebody creates some
sort of a free project
it starts gaining traction uh and they
decide
hey maybe i'm tired of supporting this
thing
because honestly it's a pain constantly
supporting code that's that's changing
uh and so that they want out and
somebody else offers them a whole bunch
of money and says
hey we want to take over your code uh
here's a lot of cash
and they're like great i went out um
here you now control the code i'll let
my users know you're controlling the
code now
and then what happens is that company
now that now controls the code
you know maybe they insert something
into the code uh
because it's no longer a free project
maybe they added some spying software
tracking software uh or you know maybe
something more malicious
uh so you know
this is potentially a problem so yeah
there's a lot of free software out there
that's great
uh and you know i don't want to get
people too paranoid
but uh do pay attention if the free
software that you are using
changes hands or is sold to another
company uh you need to
know who now owns the software and if
you trust them
okay um here's another uh
attack technique i ran into this one's a
little bit scary
this is vulnerabilities in the original
ip protocol
and so you may recall that the ip
packets
bounce around the internet and they can
get rerouted in different directions
depending on what the internet traffic
looks like
and so what happens in this type of
attack is that
the attacker starts sending information
out about how the internet traffic is
doing
and forces internet packets through
their particular computer
so as an example in 2010 15
of all internet traffic went through
china for 18 minutes due to a
quote misconfiguration of china telecom
servers so traffic reddit through china
included internet traffic from the us
senate the army
the navy the air force the office of the
secretary of defense and
nasa so basically what happened here was
china claims this was accidental but
what happened was
china's telecom company
um basically told the rest of the
internet hey you should route your
traffic through us
uh we are the fastest way to get to your
destination
so uh you know if you're sending
information from the pentagon
to the white house it'll be faster if
you route it through china
and the internet blithely went along
with that and sent
all the ip packets through china uh in a
different incident
20 in 2013 internet traffic from mexico
to the us was rated
routed through belarus um for similar
reasons
and you know there's really no reason
why traffic will go through belarus if
it was
starting in mexico in antenna for the
u.s um
so what could this be used for well for
one thing if there's anything
unencrypted any unencrypted packets
going through
uh those can just be read and this also
you know we talked a minute ago about
how in the man on the middle attack you
need to get between
the person and the computer uh they're
communicating with well
using a technique like this you are now
in the middle between
that person and the community computer
they're communicating with
all right so um
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the variety of
different ways computers can get
attacked of course there are many other
ways computers can get attacked but
uh you know i hope this gives you a
sense of the broad range of
things that can happen to attack
computers
again let me emphasize the social
engineering one because and the phishing
attacks and the spear phishing because
that is the one that
you are best able to personally protect
against
um if you're completely freaked out now
well i'm a little freaked out myself
um but in the next lecture we will talk
about ways
you can protect yourself and defenses
against
various types of attacks i look forward
to
talking to you then